.
Across America with Jimmy
failla.
>> Well if the band sounds
fired up its because they are
folks joining me now in studio
haha not only the Queen of
daytime not only national
best-selling author but hot off
the presses.
>> We've got a new book out
it's called fate still move
mountains miraculous stories of
the healing power of prayer.
Harris Faulkner is in the House
a girl. Well, hello you are
mine.
>> My seatmate at the Patriot
awards that's the thing and it
was so much
fun and you you killed it on
stage I mean Harris so funny
because I haven't seen you
live. Yes I was trying to
studio that on that that's done
it's true that was actually
first I want you to stand up
and I'll be honest. I was
slightly distracted. There was
a woman at the head table in a
yellow dress.
Do you know it's it's so funny
because the patron awards as I
said on stage. It's the Oscars
with camouflage
okay we're saluting a lot of
brave heroic men and women I
wear my camera on the girl he
says that he and I had a 3 foot
long ponytail so I was really
thrown some that was it was so
gay actor, but I for me
selfishly I love that because I
was sitting next to you and you
get so much camera time because
you are a human parade float.
>> So I'm just saying
it's full. I'm just like she
actually has a person who
throws lollipops behind her as
she walked down the tunnel
where actual parade float, but
I got so much screen time just
by sitting at your table.
It was a win. You just get
turned into Charlie wonka haha.
Whatever you got candy 3 and
thrown behind this and you've
got moves really quick. We have
so much substance to get into,
but you said something to me
you're doing a digital
book signing. In the villages
that were the scissor explain
this to
>> Barnes and Noble down in the
villages of Florida and I'm so
excited.
>> We did something at the
Patriot awards and I've been
doing it ever since at book
signings we started doing
her circles OK that's what I
realize is when people read
faith still moves mountains
just the title of it. They
begin to contemplate what they
can do in their own lives and
that's that's the journey for
me I mean I'm called to be a
not called the prophesies the
divine assignment on my life is
to tell other people's stories,
I'm a journalist and it just so
happens that these are faith
testimonies these stories are
and people are finding them as
like fuel to the fire and
they're ready to pray and I say
will lower altogether don't
look Fauci we're going to hold.
>> and then everyone gets a
ticket for not social
distancing. It's a whole to do
you know what we're all taking
it for the team they they want
to rebel there till today that
Harris Faulkner well you talk
about the spiritual team, let
me give you a great line that's
in this book is a fascinating
book. Your guy listening to the
show. You specifically would be
drawn to its weird the
vernacular of this book about
prayer. Here's the Lonnie ready
for it I wrote this down I
wrote it down okay,
right before the passage on
persistence because you know
you break the book down along
OK, okay this is the law
prayer is more than just
wishful thinking it's
discipline. It's warfare.
It's how we fight back against
darkness like to guy like me
who like you know I grab one of
those intellectually stunted
houses where we can only guess
we can only communicate through
sports references
you know, I mean that's good to
give its like it's it's it's
bad news I'm like the Yankees
sock but it's a good news on
the Yankees, you know that's
how you know is communicated
many left, but they were
inaccurate or of this book it
really is pretty cutting
in that it speaks to the
sufficiency and all of us of
wanting to do better and do
better for those around us.
I actually really enjoy this.
One Harris Hill. Thank you I
know I was raised by aware that
there are a lot of warriors in
the Bible and what I try to get
people to do at can you believe
you read the book so I feel
blessed for that because you
know Jim is
>> but what I want people to do
is to whatever season that
they're in a look at this book
is kind of and in tree. An
entryway to
better best whatever is coming
and it doesn't matter what age
you are, although tremendously
a lot of young people are
reading the book
because it teaches you how to
get started praying, there's a
glossy insurgency waters loves
this him because he loves the
glossy answer and those are
original prayers got
together with a theologian to
come because it's got to be
sure. Yeah because other people
can't imagine that's why they
don't always turn to the Bible,
it's it's they're not quite
there yet and their faith walk.
So the idea of
a warrior, the world wants us
to give up the fight you get
this is real spiritual warfare
Israel. The devil is alive also
he's
not well. But he's alive he's
lot in the planet he's got a
lot of disciples
and if we want great things in
our lives against all the
obstacles that will always fake
face you know I lost my dad on
Christmas Day in 2020. Now I
don't have a living parent of
my kids are still young that's
a mountain and I've been
praying about how do you move
the the sorrowful heart that I
still have for the last 2
years. But you do prayer way
through it. Yes do you
get it on Paris partners in
studio. The new book Fay still
moves mountains miraculous
stories the healing power of
prayer.
>> I have one announcement
kamala Harris. So in the last
72 hours.
>> I have a number one New York
Times best-selling book Wahoo.
>> Take
off
out tonight, you're just call
me away said how we see we are
going out tonight
and congratulations. That's a
big deal it is a big honor
dress back As is back it might
be money green now girlfriend,
let's not lie. And by
the way well, I wouldn't even
know that was coming that's how
good the audio timing is on the
show just said
you just said that and we knew
to have the Jeffersons rat
yeah, I know what I'm messing
around Harris Faulkner. So let
me ask you this because faith
can move but can faith.
>> Move domestic energy
production back to this country
because there's things going on
in Venezuela right Corsicana my
audience has a lot issue if you
take it away, I mean.
>> This is Clinton's Apple is
at work here right, yeah, let's
have a would love for us as a
beacon of light on this planet
to do business.
With the dirtiest oil providers
with dictators and by the way I
wondered if this was still true
so I started looking at this
screams often spill out.
This is in the Washington Post
screams often spill out in the
halls of the headquarters of
Venezuela's intelligence
service agency investigators
say.
They found that detainees who
are often journalists activists
are government opponents are
routinely subjected to beatings
rape
electrical shock. Udall ation
expect see ation and other
types of torture. This was
dated less than 45 days ago
that's insane and this is with
us still guys September 21st
2022 at 08:44AM in the morning
Eastern time that story at the
Washington Post and so why
is Biden and his administration
why are they doing a deal with
Venezuela. So that Chevron can
go and produce oil there but we
can't be energy independent why
senior administration say
because they want to ease the
sanctions. Not driven by the
oil market pressures of prices
instead to respond to
Venezuela's regimes does this
decision this week to negotiate
with the opposition groups
they're torturing that yes
as of September 24, I mean do
they think stupid. Yes, they
and yes God can move that
mountain but you got to get the
first so so we're in it for the
warfare with our prayers here
and all of that aside back to
the politics for just a second.
Do they think we're stupid.
They do, but they do think
we're stupid that's
the problem. It why can't we do
what we can do here Jimmy well,
the frustration is I think for
a lot of people.
>> That there might be good
intentions behind the green
energy movement.
>> But those good intentions
are the vessel through which
the drinking, their people that
don't understand the energy
market or don't understand the
economy because there's no
world where we can get out of
bed and do this without fossil
fuels probably in the next 200
act. We can't so bad but
knowing that's the starting
point. The floor just
pretending from here
and if we're burning fuel clear
in this country by outsourcing
it to other countries what I
would say is this is like you
know the Mafia does get their
hands dirty they cut a check
for somebody else to do the
deed that's we're doing this is
an AC DC song dirty deeds done
dirt cheap, we're
having them produce this energy
but then what does it cost more
energy to get back into the
country. So all these clean
energy people need maybe they
are good okay, maybe some of
them are good okay well, but
yeah, not everybody out there
yes, but that doesn't mean they
understand at which point you
know if you're in a bar in your
body is acting up, you get him,
it's got to go get him is going
to Alyssa
Milano haha.
>> She's so good at this you
should have 2 I
do I know where I'm one of them
Harris FOX is in studio.
So listen a lot over the
weekend so great, I love a
celebrity virtue signal more
than anybody I like people who
Hill is that we're at a look
here but stick with me now and
can we get them.
So listen a lot over the
weekend announces to the world
that she's traded in are tesla
for Volkswagen.
>> Because Elon musk is
empowering Nazis by allowing
free speech on the app at which
point she is quickly educated
about the fact that
Volkswagen's origins aren't the
best origin story when it comes
to World War 2 in their
involvement with the Nazis
which was kind of funny and I
think she was on the wrong end
of a ratio of about 98. 1000
likes within the first hour
that's pretty crazy stuff.
But what I find fascinating is
we've turned a lot of politics
Harris into a branding exercise
and branding meaning it
reflects well on you personally
and your social circles to say
hey I care about the
environment or I care about
people I care about injustice.
But there is as you just said
so much injustice
behind the green energy
movement whether it's Venezuela
torturing people or us getting
up solar panels that are made
in the week a province of China
where they're produced at a
slave labor breaking time but
that's what we're doing those
are facts so it's it's good
branding to say I support green
energy, but if you look an inch
below the surface there is so
much human injustice.
>> So how did branding in that
sense. Also because how could
it be coupled with I
know nothing I don't read.
I don't study in fact, I'll
just tweet with no knowledge
that smoke, it said that its
most of what's out there.
>> Because it's the convenience
of us in social media again
it's not so much about getting
that judgment and yes they are
being judged for for knowing
the difference between cow
patties and yeah, and chocolate
cookies haha well there's a lot
in the book.
>> Okay that really does apply
to what we're doing in
politics, I'm just going to
bounce back and forth.
>> Early on in the book eat
I've never had anybody do
book I know everybody
usually just read the jacket
moves on with their life know
Harrison you're going to come
by and talk about your book
we're going to read the book
and discussing he read it
there's a line early on we talk
about everyone's individual
faith journey and how it's all
Ikea furniture and that there's
some assembly required
to quote.
>> I even read that you know
from your brain growth from
paying attention okay, but
stick with me now.
I find that so fascinating
because I think in this day in
age that overlaps with
everything not just your faith
journey, but your political
journey because what are we
discussing there's a lot of
people out there that didn't
build the furniture. They just
want the credit for being like
hey I want them
you know whatever the dressers
call their the crash whatever
it's called, but they didn't
bother to build its own over
the talking about.
>> You know and wow I it's it's
a fascinating taking you on a
book tour. I'm saying. Villages
I'm coming back
welcome back to see the low
they would love that they heard
him
to Ohio. Better on the line
we're going to talk about this
well she's deceased yeah
very long that no you know it's
interesting because.
>> Not knowing. And going
to find her faith and tapping
into prayer and tapping into
the Bible.
That sure season and got
me chew right there not knowing
in in jumping into the world of
twitter it's not reality and it
requires that you know some
stuff because when you don't
then you find out that the
company that you treated your
American made tesla for you was
started by Nazis. Under the
German labor front which was
Hitler's you
and then a year later when they
I don't know what they figured
out, but they decided to call
the company the people's
company. Yeah, I'm not really
sure what was going Include the
but how could she not
even.
>> Think I'm going to trade in
American made vehicle Alyssa
Milano and then.
I'm just going to throw out all
directions in life like Ikea
furniture just throw it out
winning it and go out and buy
the one car.
Your this reference should not
have bought now in the Assembly
required version of that tweet
she did not bring an Allen key
to the Falkland haha we're like
this over with.
>> People may still
lose Matt in the sober hit the
Book of life a snow moves
mountains, miraculous stories
of the healing power of prayer
month or 2 I that blew me away
really quickly, one of them is
about the horrific movie
theater shooting out in Aurora
Colorado during of you know
showing of the bomb was amazing
with the mom hovers over the
kid, the mom goes into prayer.
>> And says she is soon she's
going to die, but has somehow
made peace with the scenario
because I guess prayer had just
leveled her out.
>> When you hear stories like
that because that's the stuff
to me that's the most powerful
because it's in a situation of
absolute helplessness
where you actually feel like
you've somehow help yourself
and that's why I think this
book is really empowering to
people even if they're on the
fence about religion and the
role that faith plays in
shaping who we are that's a
really profound moment because
it's not a person saying
you know it's all going to work
out it's just a price and you
know thanks for the memories of
the captain going down with the
ship miraculously winds up not
going Well and it's also a
person who's not saying I give
up yeah.
>> I give this to God
Ernestine in the pro clauses
yeah, all of those houses along
her block in twenty-nineteen
Lee County.
>> Alabama I I believe
former president Trump went
there when this outbreak it
happened it was so monumental
at the time. At the time 3
years ago.
When she survives broken hip
from the from the twister
outbreak she survives inside a
structure that sweat and Warren
from all of the rain and when
you have everything when the
EMT show up she's screaming.
Thank you Lord, thank you, and
she said she
prayed thank you for the life
you've given me and if it is
your will.
Thank you for what's ahead
while she was surviving the
storm. That is mustard seed
faith that yeah that we talk
about it's it's indestructible
it seems tiny and then it
grows.
>> To where we reach God with
that faith in just a moments
notice. But it is his timing
you're right it doesn't always
mean that you survive or that
you come out. You know the way
that you want to come out of
something but the storm.
It is important that's why you
pray in life and things are
good before the storms com.
I'm so right now I'm pulled
over but that you would agree
on anything but stop and Harris
Faulkner, I feel so blessed by
that I know you're raising a
child a teenager like I am a
couple of them.
And when they see us do the
things that Lee work. Rather
than what the world tells them
yeah. That is the that is such
powerful parenting and I know a
lot of parents are reading the
book and I'm very grateful.
I want to say thank you, it
means a lot that you're reading
it. We are there as parents we
are the offensive line of I
>> Is that don't show up nobody
call about an offense of law
you give him a Aaron hahahaha
long one was a long one for the
Packers she always leave you
with some foot. And now of
course you are.
>> Big day for Harris Faulkner
in the high-flying Kansas City
Chiefs, the book Fay still
moves mountains. Miraculous
story of the healing power of
prayer read it call and you can
discuss it I'm pretty well
versed without hair, yeah, a
second-string copy editor at
this point but I can I ask you
a quick question.
>> We talk about
like the pair closet places to
prayer we say you need a time a
place and to be alone every day
doesn't have to be fancy does
them to be a long time where do
you like to press
for real.
>> It's usually 2 places OK,
one is just up at night just
talking about things. Yeah a
lot of gratitude in my life
there's other weird thing I do
when I do this in I pray
for random people like I just
pass them on the street to you
and I might take it to help
help that check out she's a
mess or she looks like she's
having a good day care and make
it better or that guy or they
are in an assessor is that with
that is that with that that's
called it is and a lot of times
people say girl a pray for you
and they don't because they
don't know tha